тут тут стоячи в буду і ніг його
дитинства
клаусу теляк було дев'ять школи йому
довелося ж покинутий рідний місця costs
in
ще була в чому струминного на городецькому та
бомбарду вільні комі за годину-другу
світлове провини
ти зайшли порався був у брутальна руїна
ванні в раз ми завищилася вони з чим
новим woman через зростання місця територія
поштою кілочки журналі стиль сокира
проводити тут чим алича су бін показуючи
двом польським сукам ніж скорботи в мєста
дай йому вірна пухова на його сімейна
історія
тут була команда туру, а ось тут бубни
буду и ног 2 тату тату адже будинку малий
ще зал і шилась людині нам подобається
вид коп а ти підвал все ще любиш я там
по році чудо вихідних мої родичі малий
адже справжній цінності середні
столові прилади на 24 окремо в пар цилі
ну а моя мати
захворів а тут ти ще було впораюсь і
нести вусі годинник ще на і менше 20 банок
з ковбасою а за bigboss
батьківщина була збентежена залишити і все також
частка спить колу близько 12 мільйонів у ньому
ті ж optical і світла добра вільна година
праймусу
якщо по волині від нацистського немечений
клаус стиль марія знай ти хочеш загадку
про минуло то схожі марну співачка і з'їсть
ігри відкинеться до п'ятниці
підвал засипані великою кулею землі ще
кидка по ти потрібна інша техніка
відкопати тобто все трагедія рахунку
сказати про людину пробують де 100 тис
api 2 лози і шоу боку поки клаус стиль
чека ясно двір of prophecy і нішу якість
кардіфф пробираються в зайву перевалку
німецькі солдати окопи вал з аптекою
тут часом чи буде vsa місцях хіт за
барони але дали сукач і тужить мужик
нора стиснуті свої жити а на bespeco
хочеш га бу ба hal і бомба вивчила в
будинок верхній поверх обвали все саме
ж зваляться і буде якимсь цим
цар мовою вона справа одна клаус стиль
за дублони результатом пожартував а g-shock
а чиїй скорботи в чи знаєш та ще щоб він
від 70 рук у тому наклав оммаж кінці
будинку
а то пара розбудило в ногу з пагоди
дитинства ручний то це було дуже дорога
партс чи вона чорнильницями вівса ряди
їй чоловік від балтійського моря для мене
шкіра з їх промов пробу g
емоції на виток шивани наклав йому їй
раді не
вони могли на лежати і людям і до них я
знав конга
шоку через скорботи він і зміг знайди
статус підвалу будинку детства клаус
готелю провини цілком нині продовжу в цьому
з проби то пушок і будай щурів свободи
таїнство для нього стелила мене
про